you laugh you lose
oh the challenge is on
jacksepticeye
probably best youtube all right it's
finally
a new challenge for real this time we
have high
stakes jack has suggested himself that
the loser
has to sing i didn't suggest that you
suggested that
okay it was my idea
i just want to hear you saying bro i
don't want to sing at all
and the other person gets to pick the
the song
already are you ready to laugh or not
laugh do we get lives or is it just like
okay you laughed at that one okay
you get three lives and then you die
from shame of singing
in front to be fair if i die three times
over the fourth time
probably should be final so uh-huh yeah
all right here we go
it's not even funny actually
[Music]
that counts
no does that count yourself okay okay
cyber is judge what does science say
it doesn't count okay the council of
cyber spoken
yeah if we make each other laugh that
doesn't count the meme has to make us
laugh
yeah turns out i'm not very good at on
like chopping
no you're not i feel like this is
something i would do and it hurts
i'm i'm afraid to speak now because i'm
afraid i'll just giggle at something
and then i'll lose my life i'm not i'm
not singing here today
i'm laughing at your joke okay fine you
really
don't want to say it i thought this was
r funny
yeah i was the funny i thought it was
funny but i didn't live
a breakdown of my morning shower shampoo
60 seconds
soap 90 seconds mentally prepare for
whatever [ __ ] the universe has in
store for me today
15 minutes damn so relatable
that's so relatable i don't really
prepare for what the day is about to be
though
not really i just don't shower same bruh
honk if you'd rather be watching the
1999 cinematic masterpiece the mummy
starting brandon fraser
and rachel wine oh god
cringe this is a very reddit pose isn't
it
yeah that's a reddit
[Laughter]
it probably just says have an op dude
somewhere else on the character
we've always felt there's been a bit of
a gap in our capabilities so we're
really really
enthusiastic about announcing this new
squad the uh small area
urban search and guided evacuation oh
they're so cute
this is adorable wait this is our cue
not
[Music]
the cars under close up and things like
that we're also going to be able to
attach them to drones
yeah which is you know that's really a
game changer for you that's laughs
that's a laugh you
laughed side side would be the judge
that's one strike fine it caught me off
guard i wasn't ready for it
thank god because i kind of laughed as
well okay
we'll review the footage fencing the
perfect coved sport
gloves stab anyone who gets closer than
six feet
hey not funny though next not funny just
factual
oh my god that's photoshopped yeah it
must be oh
i read the type i read the title of it
of course it's photoshopped i'm such an
idiot
yeah dumb
i was laughing at you laughing damn it
nah i left first okay
is that how we do it sure yeah i like
those rules two two
let's go chat now i can laugh at it
let go as somebody who is a tiny child i
can relate to this
i was very very small this you
bro does you like goldman
like all right that's great it feels
good to laugh i
breached the damn so that's two-two
right
yeah okay i get it cause boat's stuck in
river
canal it's the same it's land bone
the 70 000 of you who have upvoted this
i should be absolutely ashamed of
yourselves
thank you i agree our funnies are cringe
sometimes
it's uh well that's any subreddit it's
true
what is it i don't get it
oh it's an egg that's it oh
it's egg day you look under your dad's
beard
idiot you deserve it guys and girls
and everybody just look under your dad's
beards every now and then they didn't
check his ass either
check your
[ __ ] rookies i wish there was a way
of filtering videos only
yeah wait what is happening
oh my god
oh that was so hard he's a dog smoker
that was a good one dogs are your weak
point oh man
he's seen some [ __ ] does edgar ever do
that does he ever look at the tv and
react to it edgar hates
sharks and we're watching shark tank and
every time the [ __ ] shark comes he
loses his goddamn mind
every god every animal there's no actual
sharks on shark tank you know that right
yeah it's just in the outbreaks and also
now because of it
anything blue on screen he'll just lose
my night wow yeah
have laughed himself into being able to
have loved himself the
idiot well he he's not afraid he just
thinks he's tough but he's
like lamest dog ever they only seen him
run
yeah that's true the only time he ever
barks is that something is like
leaving him if a bike passes really fast
he's like yeah
you better run [ __ ]
i trained him well i trained him well
okay
i like that i like that too
i literally i did this to your baby once
and i thought it was normal like i told
you it feels like a very you thing to do
yeah and i stared back at the baby and i
didn't see the dad next to the baby
going
what the hell are you doing and i'm just
we were just having a
stare off what can you imagine
what the [ __ ] are you doing it looks
like such a creep
so i'm looking at my kid your child was
threatening me so i threatened bank
what's the problem officer officer
probably was a car oh this is the one
that looks like ken
looks like ken yeah there was someone
everywhere but i haven't seen the ken
one ah
it really looks like hand i saw the shoe
when i saw ken and i see nothing else
is this some celebrities shoe i think it
is i think i read the car
oh it definitely looks like him okay
meanwhile in the swiss canal
all right well this meme is so dead now
oh they even
made the joke even clearer by putting
the thing on top
i'm so glad i had no idea where that was
going until i saw the photoshop
okay that's just kind of awesome yeah
this looks like something from a ghibli
movie oh yeah
it does the little sup monsters oh my
god
i'm i wasn't laughing at the house
you're laughing i laughed that uh
come on i didn't count you're laughing
yeah okay fine but it didn't count
no safe taking hey thank you i will give
you a raise
oh he's never given you a raise no
matter how much he's ever said that
oh what was that okay i would consider
giving you a raise wow bribery
so okay two two we got him nice that was
close
thanks you're a real g car crashes into
building
he's watching himself on the news uh
dude have your moment you're famous now
i like how he checks the phone again
just to make sure am i in frame oh they
zoomed in
time to dance more oh here we go they're
definitely me
they're crunching me on me gotta do that
move again
i'm not laughing at this guy if we're
laughing at us making fun of it
yeah right that's us in 10 years that's
us
definitely oh i've seen this whoa
whoa that skill dude
that's some anime [ __ ] deal have you
seen those videos where everything just
works out perfectly i don't know what
they call
like humans being awesome or something
you have this crazy chance
i that's how i want my life to be you
just want to be a human being awesome
all the time
yes if a genie comes knocking that's
what they do right
knock knock it's me oh hello come in
would you like to buy three wishes oh
it's a sale
[ __ ] pyramid scheme for wishes your
ponzi scheme
by now everyone's getting in on it he's
i'm german too all right
if you buy three wishes you can give
three wishes to your friends
and they can give three wishes to their
friends yes the package only costs nine
thousand
life of opportunity fancy genie
uh yeah i'd pick to be able to do this
kind of [ __ ] all the time
wouldn't that be awesome that is pretty
cool yeah that's a good one right
mine is just i want to teleport i'm so
sick of having to use my likes
oh my god dude that's so good i want to
fly everywhere i was like yeah but you
get tired and you get lazy you don't
fly i want to flap my wings you know if
you got teleport
in hollywood they always ruin all the
cool [ __ ] they're like he's going to
teleport into a wall or some [ __ ]
right yeah that none of that none of
that i just teleported just tell them
like like the couch with like a beer in
my hand
can you tell about other things too oh
[ __ ] i can teleport like cheetos to my
mouth
what was this video about again why
bother going through your mouth just go
directly in your
digestive system i don't eat them
because
i'm hungry i eat them because nom nom
tastes good
oh you're what you're one of those all
right
man if only the subreddit was as funny
as we are yeah yeah
here we go eight-year-old girl there's
an impression on her of her mother
um hi jennifer so that's pretty good
um okay be quiet don't get too close
yeah sorry about that um so tonight is
gonna be fun yeah
they're snapping that's pretty good yeah
um
yeah the dog is very crazy um
so yeah yeah it's going places it's hard
to multitask you know
yeah that's cute that's sweet
you ever got snapped by your parents
what did they do actually
i got sniped for sure hey mom can i get
a hot
wow if you were just an annoying kid
probably
was that brighton oh man the guards
behind almost got me
i didn't expect that
she just gives up okay can we can we
laugh now
okay i feel like we've broken so many
rules
it was so mad at us
it was funny but i didn't like it sure
what's happening
in beers how are you just going to push
down all at once
how oh if one slaps real hard
but there would they're going to break
what do you think
i think one of them will open and that's
it german engineering fail
[Applause]
well done oh it's just one
oh and now all the lads get to have
[ __ ] ears together
that was sick that was pretty sick we've
been life though
no i was just impressed mm-hmm
[Laughter]
animals are too funny you forgot where
i was trying so hard to listen to what
the lady was saying i didn't know what
the dog was doing
[ __ ] man stealth hundreds
meme up on screen i'd laugh at that at
this point you want some facebook memes
coming up
all right we're both at one jack this is
it no more jokes
no more easy mode oh no it's more pets
he's right there i know he hears me
oh this is the cat he's trying to get
food
anytime you put text over animal clips
though i kind of zone out really
yeah it hurts jack
give in give in look at him
he's just a tiny little man
oh i swallowed it i'm good i'm good yeah
you passed that weight
yeah yeah two stars that's what i rate
this video oh come on
get it out of my face it's cute but you
put text over and ruined it
come on no no i'm a hair judge
you don't like text over it why you
don't like tick tocks or something what
do you say well the cats are fine
it's just the dogs it's always like he'd
do a heck in bamboozle like okay
now you're ruining it what are they
doing
oh my god the pandas are so cute
oh they look so fluffy yeah i want to
hug one
i'll snap at you
[Applause]
pandas just want to have a good time
it's like dealing with children oh my
god they're so annoying but they're so
cute
dude they are living their best lives oh
it hurts
it hurts so much okay i'm afraid to
speak
i'm over it i'm over it whatever pandas
you've seen one penny you've seen them
all yeah yeah yeah
oh my god they're so annoying i wouldn't
even bother trying to clean this up
what's the point give up yeah that's the
point
oh god it's so long let me oh
oh my god dude okay i'm good
i'm good you good yeah not even i'm good
i've never laughed
once ever true why is it always the
animals that get me
yeah well because
because they're not putting on a
pretense they're just themselves
dude that's deep yeah you just dissected
the internet i
oh oh there's a wood picker in my
neighborhood
this street every morning i can't help
but imagine he's thinking damn the tree
is impeccable
he's good he's a little confused oh but
he's got the right spirit
i heard a woodpecker for the first time
in real life there was one
in like a tree uh nearby and he was just
doing
in uk oh i've never heard it in real
life oh [ __ ]
there's a lot of them in sweden oh
oh no oh no
[Music]
he's so mad oh [ __ ] that's an angry
kitty
that's a playful doggy
ah diet potato
that could have been dangerous that
could have been dangerous
oh this is
i mean i got this is easy oh another
animal
oh oh
oh i had to look away
what is that face oh that was so close
oh my god another animal jack oh damn it
oh it's not a video we're fine can't
regretting our choice to go outside
if we see a kid fall over i'm fine
that's it i'll be done
okay let's google child fire no
i don't want that in my searching what
you dare
a gif nah get out of here so woody
holland
yes tech tips with uncle rob today i'm
going to show you how to fix your broken
internet okay this might be good
unplug your router then wait five
seconds
plug it back in i never wait the five
seconds plug it back in
then unplug it again then
plug it back in then
fill a 55-gallon drum with gasoline you
knew something crazy was coming
yeah throw your router in the barrel
this is such a boomer thing
plug the router into a car battery oh
good lord
poor router whoa
then call comcast and tell them to [ __ ]
off
wow that guy's got it down that guy gets
women doesn't get internet my entire
uh female demographic just disappeared
they went to uncle rob
instead oh you
come on bro
stinky can a cigarette lighter
light i know it's not gasoline but i was
thinking about it
candidly is that enough you know we
shouldn't be asking these questions
moving on
why you like that one no i don't get it
elon mask
i'll give it a i'll give it a sec
[Music]
oh okay no no i don't get it
like elon musk that's it elon mask
that's it that's the joke
that's that's the joke oh okay that was
at least used a picture of him or
something
there's no way you're gonna break
something like that if we can't be
friends anymore if you cry
i respect that okay i haven't seen this
gas station worker takes precautionary
measures after customer refuse to put
out a cigarette
i have seen this okay so now we will
know so who who has a cigarette
guy in the fight it's coming
it's coming a fire extinguisher i knew
it yep
[Music]
yeah okay it's cool but not funny come
on come on yeah that's not
really funny it's not a baby or a cat
like what's the point
yeah baby fall over go high
all right have you seen this yeah ah
come on
i'm not cracking okay that's pretty dope
this is dub
this is not funny
[ __ ] no way that got you
[Laughter]
oh my god you're such a dad
he came out of nowhere i knew the jokes
[Music]
what do you want ask to be copyrighted
do it anymore no no how dare you jack
you're banned you're banned for like
that's so slow
it's a good song actually i like that
yeah i'm not gonna lie
i felt more like a wave everyone's just
cringing when they try and get you with
it
nah oh yeah but it's a good song
totally worth it that's it that's full
circle well play jack you may have won
this round
thank you smash like subscribe if you
want more check out jack
channel apparently only 12 percent of
people
12 that's way too low what the hell
happened 88
go down or off i forget which one i said
all right that's it bye